a champion of the weird and the wacky it
was only a matter of time before Tim
Burton tackled The Adams Family
franchise non-conforming women such as
Lydia and Sally are just some of
Burton's most iconic characters and
modernizing Wednesday Adams was a
no-brainer Netflix's Wednesday is a
fresh spin on the character honoring her
Latina roots and making her even more of
an outsider than before this was an
element that the new Wednesday herself
Jenna Ortega was hoping to elevate
Ortega stated in a Netflix feature at it
was really important to me that I did
something different even though she's
been done so flawlessly in the past
she's a bit more socially awkward
there's a confidence there but it's more
concealed there is no question that
Christina ricci's portrayal in the 90s
is beyond reproach but Ortega's Instinct
about the character did not end up being
a gamble critics immediately began to
praise Ortega's distinctive Direction
with the iconic character The Wall
Street Journal wrote Miss Ortega is a
charismatic performer playing a
character who is decidedly anti-charisma
so that's an accomplishment she has a
face that triumphs over deadpan
it's no surprise that Ortega is
receiving a bundle of praise for
starring as one of TV's most iconic goth
icons or take a lenter talents to the
horror Thrillers scream and X earlier
this year but it's clear that Wednesday
is Holy hers after the series premiered
on Netflix fans couldn't get enough of
the young actor's take on the iconic
Addams Family character Wednesday isn't
the first time television introduced us
to team sleuths Veronica Mars gave us
Kristen Bell's pithy titular detective
while the characters of Riverdale would
be nowhere without Jughead Jones leading
the investigative charge Jenna Ortega's
Wednesday Adams is the next to pick up
the mantle in this Gothic High School
series with many praising the show's
mystery fans on Twitter have exploded
with praise for the Netflix series one
user wrote this show is so iconic Jenna
Ortega is easily one of the best actors
of Our Generation and I love that it was
a murder mystery it was like Adam's
family meets Sherlock this was just
first of many instances where Ortega
received continuous Praise on social
media an enthusiastic viewer tweeted the
first episode of Wednesday was freaking
amazing it's absolutely ridiculous how
amazing Jenna Ortega is as Wednesday the
score the writing the visuals the acting
everything is on point though the series
came together as a whole there has been
one continuous thread throughout the
fans love of the series one fan in
particular said finished Wednesday and
I'm left with the biggest smile on my
face Jenna Ortega ate that up leaving no
crumbs what a ridiculously talented
woman
across the board fans could not get over
her command of the character several
Twitter users echoed similar sentiments
about the comedy coming across in Spades
Jenna Ortega has had considerable
experience in television for some time
but the actor has truly come into her
own in the past couple of years thanks
to her recent leading and supporting
horror roles the Wednesday actor has
become a true icon for the genre those
who have completed the series think the
star truly shines as the goth hero a
Reddit user commented while discussing
the series on the television subreddit
Jenna is awesome and I'm loving her
she's the best part of the show and in
every scene she's great another user
suggested that Ortega's success is
Wednesday is due to her ability to
embody the character fans know and love
while also updating it for modern
audiences truly making it her own some
were more critical of the Netflix series
though even they couldn't deny Ortega's
active chops a redditor wrote Jenna
Ortega is the only saving grace and
carries the entire show on her back it's
palpable how inexperienced her co-stars
are compared to her while some Tim
Burton fans couldn't get into the show
others couldn't help but feel Joy seeing
Ortega tap into Wednesday's Latina Roots
one Twitter user called out and praised
Ortega for representing the Latin
Community saying Jenna Ortega as
Wednesday Adams is everything Latina
empowerment overall it looks like
Wednesday is another winner for Burton
Netflix and Ortega whose career is just
starting to rise
foreign
[Music]